what do you think by the way about your
boy elon musk because i know you love
tesla so much
saying they're going to be fully
self-driving in like what
two weeks he's he's been saying that for
like three years yeah a lot of people
think he's full of [ __ ] yeah
a lot of people think he's just foolish
but when he says stuff like that the
stock
just goes up a great yeah that's great
good
well i hope when you're in your car and
you're incinerated
the stock price makes you feel
comfortable as you and your wife are
burning to death
in your tesla because this guy told you
it was going to drive you home
maybe it will one day i don't really
know you know
everybody's so goddamn sensitive now so
if elon musk hears this uh we're kidding
elon
and we don't know if we're kidding yet
we'll let you know
hopefully ben still gets to work every
day everyone is so goddamn sad
you can't say anything about
anybody anymore without a problem you
know
like i made the joke about eric
weinstein alex friedman i was like
on the patreon i go what have these guys
done they're clearly smart guys
the joke is about the fact that like
yes they're both you know lex is uh
in robotics and everything's brilliant
guy and eric weinstein's very smart and
everything
but like you know the trans
discussion has sucked all of the oxygen
out of the room
so i'm sure these people have brilliant
takes on other issues
but is it fair to say that the trans
issue
has been on the forefront and i'm for
one
i'm a little bored of the truck i don't
care anymore if you cut your tits off or
sew a dick on
i don't care what you call yourself it
doesn't bother me
if you want to become an uh a woman
so you can beat them up in a ring i'm
almost for that as long as you look at
them before you do it and go you should
have kept your mouth
shut but what i'm saying is
i'm not saying i'm kid they're clearly
very intelligent people
but like why is everyone now a guru
why do people jump out of their lane
and they become a guru for every issue
in life no one has any type of
specialization
anymore if peop i mean
everybody is just like like
firing wildly going yeah
i i'm i'm a scientist or i'm this or i'm
not
and also i know everything
about everything i should be your go-to
for every question you have about any
issue
that could ever come up now or in the
future
that's where i get confused it's not
that they're not smart
it's not that they're not they don't
have valuable things to say i just get
confused
as to how everybody immediately becomes
a guru
overnight people just become they just
decide i
uh you got problems i'll tell you what
it is
what are we doing today race gender
sexuality vaccines what do we got
put it on the whiteboard i got the
answer i got the answer
bring it on weather war
religion what's on the grill today
sizzle it up salt and pepper it it's
ready to go i don't have to let anything
marinate i'm
ready to go it's just fascinating that's
all that's all i'm ever saying
i love everyone and support them i'm
just
curious as to how everybody uh is an
expert
in every issue that could ever arise
from any discipline ever
that's interesting to me that's all and
maybe that's the case maybe it's the
case that there are
seven intelligent people and the rest of
the world
are hacks and shills i don't know
that's youtube you go on youtube
basically
the premise of of youtube is i get it
and everyone else that's ever lived or
studied this issue
is either a bad faith actor
hack shill has been bought off
is a liar is being blackmailed and
i have figured it out and nobody else
has
that's all it's curious to me
it's curious and then if you make jokes
people get angry at you the people by
the way
who defend jokes
defend comedy and they always go out and
go comedy's being
neutered by the pc police and then you
make jokes about them and they go
ah
actually uh we don't like that
you go well wait a minute i don't
understand
i thought comedians were vital
sort i thought this was a vital activity
what and they go well yeah yeah but
i don't know i don't know
people get angry at you the same the
people get angry at you for kidding
around
and you go yeah it's a joke i'm the
comedian you shouldn't take me seriously
no one should
it's a comedy podcast maybe i say some
interesting things
maybe i'm right about some of what i say
but uh it's a goof
i look at [ __ ] that may or may not be
[ __ ] and i call it out it may not be
[ __ ]
and it may be [ __ ] but that's
where a lot of my comedy comes from uh
okay
and then the people that are like all
these people that are like
you know the comedians are being you
know there's a
the backlash now to the backlash as a
smarter friend of mine has said
is becoming as sanctimonious as the woke
people
the other side of the wok they're they
are now
as boring as the woke you know
used to watch the woke people and go
jesus christ shut
up and now the other side you're like
jesus christ should also shut up
should we just get academics completely
out of public life should we just exile
academic i don't know
but it's just this sanctimone
all the time the left is waging a war
on your private choices they want
you to be completely and then if you
you make a few and they're like and they
always love comedy all these people
because the left is insane and the woke
people do go after comedy
and they do take people's jobs and i
understand that
so the people that recognize that i
applaud
and then you go yeah but you're also a
little goofy and then they go well i
thought wait a minute wait a minute
you're giving ammunition to the other
side somebody said that to me they go
when you make fun of those people whom
you agree with i go yeah i agree with a
lot of them
but they go yeah if you make fun of me
give ammunition to the other side and go
but that's the exact argument that
leftists or not leftists per se but
you know liberal or whatever you want to
call them woke
social justice warriors that's the same
argument that they used they said
you can't make a joke about race because
you're a racist and you're giving
ammunition to racist
so if i make a joke about barry why or
whoever the [ __ ] i'm talking about eric
weinstein whatever
i'm giving ammunition to
the lunatics who think that gender is
you know created
that bill maher created gender or
whatever whatever these [ __ ] lunatics
in san francisco believe
i'm giving ammunition to them because
i've made a joke about someone that
disagrees with them
it's the same sjw playbook it's the same
exact thing
it's actually the same exact thing it's
we like comedy when it fits in the
the box of what we would like it to and
uh
it doesn't really matter it's just
comedy except if it's directed at us
it's a powerful force that must be
vanquished
it's a powerful force that must be
vanquished unless it is exactly what we
want it to be
make fun of us in the way that you want
us to be made fun of please
thank you thank you they love
roasts all these uh you know the tech
people the people on clubhouse or any of
these guys i i talked to
they're all like yeah comedy's about
roasting
no it's not roasting for the most part
is pretty stupid
there are some people that are brilliant
at it uh
geraldo and jeff frost whatever you go
back throughout history
it's important commit it's like an
important comedic skill
you should every good comic should have
a little bit of it but it's boring
it's it's you know it's it's very
formulaic
there's nothing there you're fat you're
gay you're bald you're black you're the
there's nothing there dummies but some
of the most successful people in the
world they love
roasting because god forbid a comedian
say
anything that makes them think and they
have some existential moment
so they just like can you call them a
[ __ ] please because i don't know
so when you meet a lot of these people
that are that are successful
they think the comedian's job's like
roast
them yo thrash them
you go trash that guy who can't like
is there anything more boring than that
by the way is there anything more boring
than watching people just trade insults
back and forth what
level i mean i just don't understand but
that's what a lot of
very smart very successful people love
they love watching people insult each
other
that is their idea of comedy that's what
they think it is
it's just insult pick look at a brown
guy
say he's a terrorist that's comedy
you know it's really crazy but
i don't want to get in the weeds over
this
and everybody goes then everybody's
response is like why don't i just come
on the show and we'll hash it out and
it's like no i don't
i don't want to do this for five hours
of a lecture
i don't want to do it i respect you i
think you're smart but at the end of the
day it's like
i'm so deeply suspicious of people who
level accusations
at people and then they themselves
exhibit that behavior it's like the q
and on people who are going away for
child porn
right that wasn't shocking because they
spent 18 hours a day thinking about
child porn so it's also not shocking to
me that if you call people snowflakes
for years and years and years
and then somebody says something about
you and then you actually become the
snow flag
because it's like oh you are intimately
acquainted with the idea
of what a snowflake is because you're
exhibiting those characteristics
yourself
you know it's one of the other folks
either comedy doesn't matter and it's
fun
and you can like it or not and take from
it what you want
leave the rest or it's an important
social force
that everyone needs to govern pick one
please pick one can't be everything
can be everything it can't be like hey
it's just a joke and then
when it's about something you don't like
you go whoa wait a minute
i saw that after the white house
correspondents dinner with michelle
wolfe
when she did that and then everybody
came in all the same people that were
like dudes leftists are snowflakes and
michelle
made a few jokes about trump and these
people lost their goddamn mind
i'm just learning i'm just learning
that's all i'm doing here get mad at me
i'm insignificant
i don't matter yeah i have an audience
because we have fun and we say funny
stuff
and some of it makes a lot of sense
that's not my fault
that's not my fault you know when i make
fun of gary vee i don't hate gary vee
he's probably a really good guy i'm sure
he's helped people
but the advice he gives is very vague
and general
it's uh ridiculous
the words he uses and the er the way he
arranges them
is ridiculous so for somebody to not
call that out
is uh that i wouldn't be doing my job
if i pulled up garyvee quotes and read
them aloud
and said now that i've told you these
things go
start a business you would look at me
like i was on
i was smoking rock cocaine
smoking crack you'd go wait what
and i'm like yeah you know kindness is
speed and empathy is uh
marketing is queen and content is king
and
you know gratitude is whatever go go do
it now
your gratitude is uh gratitude is speed
what whatever he's saying but i'm sure
he's a smart guy and i'm sure
he said things that have value to
certain people
but it's funny imagining people trying
to
fashion a sense of what the hell is
going on in their life and in their
business
from the quotes that dribble out of his
mouth it's you know
which is why like you can go to dinner
with people and you can become friends
with people
and i talked to a big comedian once was
like jeff bezos invited me to like his
summer camp
once and the big community was like yeah
i didn't want to go because you start to
realize as a comic
you're not supposed to be that tight
with any of these people
because you're gonna have to make fun of
them or something they do
and they're just gonna get angry with
you because they want to own you
they just want to own you you know what
i i
you know so they're not they're not like
evil malevolent people they just like
anybody want to control you they see you
they're like you're a jester
i wanna i wanna own you and i
i want you to poke fun at the things i'd
like you to poke fun at
but i don't want you to say things i'm
not comfortable with
and that's why it's just funny and i'm
like
really insignificant compared to the
person who told me the story about bezos
but
when you even the people that i'm kind
of friendly with now or
in in a i know who they are they know
who i am and we maybe go to dinner maybe
i see them
out and they uh you know or they they
have some appreciation for what i do
they like you until
you cross a line and there's always a
line there's always something
that you shouldn't say or can't say and
as a comic
you gotta make a decision you go am i
gonna be one of the late night guys
that goes on stage and reads
propaganda that's handed to them five
minutes earlier and then they got it to
like go like
yeah the wall street bats uh people are
russians
but um like you know like poor jimmy
kimmel's got to run out there and go
yeah the russian disruptors
uh in wall street bets because it's
again he didn't have that thought
does anyone think jimmy kimmel had that
thought i think jimmy kimmel came up
with that
on his way to work he left his mansion
on the way to work he goes
you know who i bet's doing this i bet
it's russian disrupt no
it was handed to him god only knows how
they got into the writers room
there's somebody from the cia in the
writers room which isn't hard to do
you know
so diversity hire right out of langley
here's your new writer
nawazi nabobolo
nawazi where do you come from uh uh
false church virginia shut up don't
worry about it uh here's the monologue
today
uh go out and say they're russian
disruptors uh okay
you know uh here's your new head writer
gina haspel
if you get if you're smarter you get
that but like that
you get that's what you got to do you
got to stay wait that's why now it's my
first episode of taxes i'm in the hill
country
and nobody's told me nobody's like uh
nobody's a fan of rips at
and it doesn't mean that i don't value
what like i have said on my show i think
eric weinstein is an
ally and somebody who i agree with
and i think the version of the world he
would like
is much some more similar to my own
than the version of the world that his
enemies
would want but that doesn't mean i can't
make a joke here i mean this is absurd
and
it's just a little crazy you know it's a
little it's a little crazy